let's talk a little oil and gas let's
talk oil and gas because it is a topic
by the way did you see the inflation
numbers that just came out this morning
7.9 that they're telling us which is the
highest in decades uh uh 7.9 percent gas
prices record breaking guy sent me pic
yesterday i was talking about gas uh the
price of it everybody's sending me a
message with what gas prices are in
different places beverly hills seven
eleven
four four uh
in beverly hills glendale was like 679
to fill up one gallon is 679. uh what
was that go back to it's 7.9 percent
40-year uh record that we saw on your
instagram yeah so so here's russia with
oil russia with oil okay i'm going to
read two stories back to back and i will
comment on it because it's uh both
around the same thing one is an insider
story
and the other one is a cnbc story so
here we go
uh number one opec chief says there's no
capacity in the world that could replace
russia's seven million barrels a day in
supply this is an insider story russian
oil experts are crucial to global supply
and there's no sources that can
compensate
for the millions of barrels the country
contributes
opec secretary general has said so far
opec and its allies known as opec plus
have shown no interest in ramping up
production leading some analysts
to say that this is contributing to the
squeeze on supply the threat on an o on
an import ban prompted russia's deputy
minister
to issue a warning and predicts oil
prices could search two ready folks
three hundred dollars a barrel and the
story right afterwards cnbc russia wants
300 a barrel it is absolutely clear that
a rejection of russian oil would lead to
catastrophic consequences for the global
market russian deputy prime minister
alexander novak said on monday let me
read this one more time to you this is a
power play i'm gonna read it to you one
more time folks listen up this is the
russian deputy prime minister alexander
novak said on monday okay it is
absolutely clear that a rejection of
russian oil would lead to catastrophic
consequences
for the global market the surge in
prices would be unpredictable it would
be 300
per barrel if not more russia's the
third largest oil producer behind u.s
saudi but u.s doesn't count because
we're not doing anything saudi arabia
didn't return
a biden's call when they reached out to
him they just didn't even call him back
and the european union received around
40 of its gas via russian pipelines
several of which run through ukraine
once again eu 40 is through russia so
thoughts on what's going on with gas
prices have you seen those stickers that
have been popping up all over the
country on gas tanks it's like a little
silhouette of biden pointing to the
price that says i did this
i think that's exactly correct this is
not russia's fault this is biden's fault
this is biden's fault because he could
have prevented what's happening between
russia and ukraine this this is this is
not something that just arbitrarily
happened this is this is a result the
war that's happening between russian
ukraine right now is a result of
deliberate actions taken by joe biden
and what i mean by that is just a couple
months ago if he had stopped the key or
if he had stopped the nordstrom 2
pipeline if he had put sanctions like
trump did on that pipeline then russia
would have backed off biden
personally lobbied democratic senators
not to reimpose those sanctions so what
happens obviously then putin is
emboldened because he knows that there
are countries like germany who rely on
him for energy meaning they're not going
to criticize him when he commits a war
act against the ukrainians right but it
goes even deeper than that it goes
deeper than that because
russian money has been funding the
environmentalist agenda in our country
for years and this is not this is not
like exclusive journalism that i'm
presenting to you this is actually
something we have known about when i say
we i mean our government officials back
in 2017 there were two republican
congressmen the story is so fascinating
to me there were two republican
congressmen smith and weber who sent a
letter to secretary of the treasury
mnuchin saying listen we have evidence
that russian state money is going
through a shell company in bermuda the
shell company is called klein limited
and klein limited is then giving as
anonymous donations to a 501 c 3 here in
the united states giving this money to
an organization called sea change sea
change is then disseminating this money
to
prominent anti-fracking anti-fossil fuel
so-called green
organizations here in our country and
the purpose of this is like vladimir
putin has been planning this attack on
ukraine for a long time this has been a
long time in the preparation because
this has worked this lobbying has worked
it has caused states across our country
to ban fracking it's caused biden to
take his stance against fracking against
using our natural resources against the
federal leases and the result of this
has been well of course when we turn to
wind or solar or anything alternative or
renewable it we still rely on coal we
still rely on oil right even even with
this green energy but when we need to
rely on oil and we're not producing it
ourselves we have to rely on russian oil
and that gives that gives a position of
leverage to vladimir putin he knows then
about it that he can
he can
invade ukraine and that nobody can
really do anything about it because they
rely on him and so when i see i know
this is a long answer to your short
question of please rant about the gas
prices but this is not something that
just arbitrarily happened this is not
something that happened overnight this
is the result of deliberate bad corrupt
choices by our politicians for a long
time for a long time
you see what uh john bolton had to say
about this situation you know who john
bolton is right the national security
adviser the most famous mustache yeah
the mustache the walrus man who was
trump's national security adviser now
you might say
they've had a falling out but he's
certainly a republican he's certainly
part of that community for sure he said
quote unquote
um that they were asked why did this is
his thoughts not mine
why did
putin delay
this invasion of ukraine he said quote
unquote putin delayed the invasion of
ukraine because putin saw what trump was
doing was doing a lot of his dirty work
for him that trump was basically being
um
hostile towards nato and he basically
thought
that
uh if he won a second term there was a
chance that
trump would pull out of nato so putin
was basically just biding his time you
know play on words right there bidding
his time to see if trump would actually
pull out of nato now
whether he was going to do that or not
there was no doubt that he was hostile
to towards nato and this is sort of
separate from the gas prices but this is
a direct answer to why putin chose this
time
but this was john bolton's opinion do
you have any strong feelings on what
john bolton has to say or what do you
think john bolton and donald trump are
on opposite ends of the republican party
and what i mean by that is there's a
dike there's a division especially when
it comes to foreign policy there's
interventionists like john bolton
they're like certainly not a dove he's a
definite warrior oh he wants to attack
iran 100 i mean he would admit this this
isn't he said it on camera yeah
yeah and then donald trump was very much
national interest he called it america
first it's really a reagan foreign
policy but he didn't want to get
involved anywhere unless he has to
unless it's in our direct national
interest it's actually closer to the
isolationist end of the spectrum um i
think i think john bolton actually
misses misses the point here i don't
think that trump was hostile to nato i
think that that was a negotiation tactic
to get nato members to pay their fair
share the u.s has been paying the
majority of dues to nato for a long time
and all of these other countries have
been freeloaders they've been taking
advantage of us as they they have enough
money they've just been using it for
their own domestic welfare systems and
just allowing the us to do it because we
would to pay this amount because we
would and so trump is calling them out
he's forcing them he's threatening them
as a negotiation tactic sure he probably
meant it all good negotiation like when
you when you make a threat like that you
have to follow through or it's not a
real threat people can sense that um but
i don't think that he ever had any real
intention of pulling out of nato i think
that he was just using this to get
people to pay and it worked they did pay
well john you you expect jon to say
anything about trump
you expect bolton to say anything good
about trump right now you know what was
his national security advisor
you remember his book but that but that
same thing with bill barr now same thing
with pence now yeah he has these people
that are sick offense to him and then
next thing you know they're out and they
talk [ __ ] about him it just seems to be
a common theme is all i'm saying right
but you step back to where this topic
started which was on you know
international oil prices there is a cold
war that's been going on for the last 25
years and it's on the price of oil it is
a cold war that's going on between
saudis and the u.s between saudis and
venezuela between the cheaters that are
in opec they're shipping and not telling
the other opec people remember it was
the saudis that wanted to [ __ ]
alberta oil sands and north dakota oil
sand and shale oil by keeping the price
of a barrel at 45 they they acted
against their own
total profit and pulled the price all
the way down there now why they do that
well they do that because you know
alberta and north dakota were not
economically feasible oil extraction
below 50 a barrel
now with the price for barrel up this is
exact time where biden can flip the
switch on energy independence where does
canada get 100 of its natural gas us the
united states now you could sit back and
say you know what let's loosen up on
this let's listen up on it and saki
yesterday that was a terribly
disingenuous answer that she gave on
this whole energy question well they've
you know they have the leases lisa's is
not a permit a permit takes forever in
washington elise's is that you have a
right to drill once you get a permit to
drill but the permits live in washington
and they the green drag feed on that so
when you look around on the oil stuff
pat this has been going back and forth
for a while and then putin's three-step
process here also was benefiting the
price and the need for the russian oil
but we gotta
also realize why those saudis didn't
return joe biden's phone call by the way
they've been playing with us for a while
as well nothing but it's not funny it's
not funny so if you enjoyed this little
segment from the podcast click over here
to watch the entire podcast and if
you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so take care everybody
[Music]
you